hey everyone welcome back and in this
video i'll be sharing how you can create
a highly scalable video delivery
infrastructure and pretty much show you
what we do at code dam if you have seen
any code damn course you know we have
videos embedded and interactive
exercises embedded as well but if you
closely look at the videos the videos
are not emitted from youtube any other
third party player for example but they
are custom optimized and delivered as
well in this video my motive is to how
not only just how to deliver but how to
create this full pipeline and this will
involve a lot of infrastructure
architecture and i know a lot of you
have been asking me this for a very very
long time so let's just go ahead and see
how we can create one also if you're new
here make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel i'll be doing more such
videos live streams and things here and
yeah i mean if you don't want to miss it
make sure you hit the bell icon
subscribe to the channel and also like
the video it helps feed the algorithm
okay so video processing where do we
even begin the first thing you have to
realize is that your video whatever
you're trying to process and put in
front of the user it has to be optimized
in a certain format the reason for this
is web currently does not support every
single video right and most of your
videos for example this video which i'm
shooting in 4k 60 fps
is 4gb for 10 minutes right and this is
exactly not what you want or what you're
watching on youtube right so youtube is
also processing this video in some
format that's why they're able to
deliver it to you so fast your internet
connection i hope is not something which
can afford 4 gb per 10 minute i mean
even if it could it's not worth it right
so what you want to do first thing is
that you take up the video which the
person has let's say this is an
mp4 video
it could be any any single format and
the first thing is to upload it to cloud
right so the very first thing you would
want to do is create a signed s3
url
now what is a signed s3 url aws is huge
right they have a lot of capacity for
compute storage and everything so what
aws allows you to do is it says that
okay we have our s3 bucket here right
it's a bucket and it can virtually store
a lot of data i won't say unlimited
because nothing is unlimited but it can
store a lot of data you cannot even
imagine so what you do is you ask s3
that hey give me an address a signed url
where whatever i put anything it just
uploads right so the compute is s3 the
infrastructure is of s3 and you don't
have to worry about what's the file size
here it could very well be one terabyte
it could be very well one megabyte right
if you route it through your own server
then you have to make sure that your
server is able to handle file of that
size or you know you're streaming it
properly to s3 then but so on but what
you do is you create a signed url from
s3 which is aws and then you upload it
to an s3 bucket
uploaded to s3 bucket this is where the
fun begins because now you have this on
the cloud right i'm gonna stick with s3
and aws and aws infrastructure because
that's how we have deployed our pipeline
at code dam but you can pretty much
choose any cloud provider i believe most
of them will provide some sort of
functionality like this now what s3
allows you to do is it allows you to
link a bucket
with a service called sqs which is a
queueing service from aws which stands
for simple queuing service so this means
let's say if i have a bucket which
stores file number one
something something file number two
something something so on what it can do
is on the next on the next upload
whatever it is right it could be a video
file it could be anything this s3 bucket
can add a message to this
queuing service and this sqs is just a
simple queue right where you read the
message and you know you can push the
message as well you can read and push
read and push so like a queue works you
have and q is a data structure data
structures are super important but not
for competitive coding only i have
created a video on competitive coding
versus software so maybe you want to
watch that as well but anyway what
happens here is that you add certain
elements and you can take them out from
the front this is this is what sqs does
but the only good thing or you know the
only major reason you should use sqs
over implementing your own queue is that
this is highly scalable right this is
highly scalable for receiving tons of
messages or tons of inputs every single
second as well which you're probably
your data structure would struggle to do
but anyway what you want to do
is every single time an item is added to
this s3 bucket you want to post push a
message to this sqs and this is inbuilt
behavior with aws right aws provides
this that whenever a file is uploaded
here a message gets added here right so
this could be
a message right
this could be a message this could be a
message let's say i uploaded three
videos together so this queue has three
messages and that's it that's where the
job for s3 ends right now aws also
provides you a service known as cloud
watch and what this cloud watch can do
is you can set an alarm
inside cloud watch to do certain action
whenever
the queue size is greater than zero so
you can create an alarm in aws that
whenever the cue size is greater than
zero i want to do something right or if
the queue size is equal to zero then
also i want to do something
right these are the two actions which we
need
in cloudwatch and i'm going to tell you
why we need these two actions this first
action right here is responsible for
launching an ec2 machine so that means
whenever the queue size is greater than
zero what we want to do is we want to
launch an ec2 server now this ec2 server
could be a powerful server as well it
could be a mini server whatever this is
but this server has two jobs the first
job
is to actually read a message from this
queue
right so this queue is there it wants to
read a message from this queue and i i
told you like we uploaded three files so
three two one for example what this ec2
server did is that it just read the
first message so it got this first
message right here and it started
processing this video file right and
what happened was this message actually
contained the path to the s3 bucket
right so this ec2 machine knows where it
needs to go and download that file that
particular file so it processes it ec2
just launches if mpeg for example we use
ffmpeg for processing you use ffmpeg and
convert this into three four formats
whatever you want for example 1080 720
360. if you want adaptive streaming and
hls and stuff like that all of that can
happen right here inside this ec2 right
because it has got access to the main
file via s3 which you uploaded here
right so the moment you do that this ec2
now has access to this mp4 file which
you uploaded right in a highly scalable
way there is no component here which
could break down or collapse under load
right given that aws in itself isn't
down and of course this does not has
redundancy built in so if for example
sqs is down you might have a loss of
message and something like that but
those things we are not discussing we
are just discussing let's say if aws is
up and we don't have any redundant
system so what is the minimum set of
which you need so once you have sqs
delivered this message to ec2 for
example and i'm assuming you are
choosing a sufficiently easy to
size so that this does not bottleneck or
you know you maybe can reject just files
over 10 gb or 20 gb whatever you process
it with a tool like ffmpeg and create
certain resolutions
the next thing is you upload them
back to a production s3 bucket
right
so for example this is your production
s3 bucket and because you have processed
a single video right here you can just
upload them back here and update any
database entries for example in our case
we link that video to a particular video
in the course right so you can update
any database entry once you do that and
you also have your video files processed
in the production s3 bucket now this s3
bucket can sit behind cloudfront right
cloudfront is a cdn service from amazon
so all the traffic which receives for
example for that video needs to go
through cloud front where you can create
these signed urls and cache this stuff
right here on the cloud front for faster
speeds right and then cloudfront can
access it in a secure way from s3
so
that is pretty much all it takes the
important part here is that one ec2 or
depending on how you want to
architecture it in our case what we have
done is one ec2
gets launched every time the q is
greater than zero and what do we mean by
that that means every single time this
is running like one for once per minute
or once for five minutes and every
single time q is greater than zero one
ec2 gets launched this ec2 takes up one
message from the queue tries to process
it if it is successful then this message
is permanently removed if this fails or
something happens then this message goes
back and it's retried again after some
time right it goes back at the end of
the queue if this keeps on failing then
we have another concept of dead letter q
dlq
which is something different which just
stores all the failed videos in case
somebody uploaded a text file for
example then of course that will fail
multiple times because it cannot be
processed by ffmpeg but yeah once you do
that this ec2 second ec2 is able to pass
the second file right here the third
file is passed by another ec2 and so on
so you see what we have done essentially
is
distributed the compute part
inside multiple ec2s and distributed the
storage part and not exactly distributed
but offloaded the storage part to s3
because s3 we know is solid right s3 has
sla of 999 i think five nines right
and this is like a solid guarantee that
your files would be available for this
much time i'm not sure if this is the
exact number but something like that
similarly the compute part ec2's a
single ec2 is handling a single file it
can take 5-10 minutes and be done with
it and deploy it to s3 that is fine
right here we use the auto-scaling group
asg
which creates all these multiple ec2's
right so the cloud watch alarm is
bounded with this auto scaling group
which increases the amount of ec2
instances and whenever this ec2 instance
is launched this this is launched from a
template which knows what it needs to do
right a snapshot or template whatever
you want to call it thanks to this asg
group and once that happens it reads it
from sqs
processes it deploys it to production s3
bucket which then is readily available
for serving to end users right now if
you go to any code damn course page for
example you will see that you have an
option to switch between 720 1080 360
480 qualities right so that is because
we have formatted it into four formats
and
delivering it via s3 right all right so
we have discussed q greater than zero
for q equal to zero what happens is that
this is zero like i said if there is
truly no video to process and this is
also zero if all of the ec2 for example
we have
two ec2s
which are processing two videos right
then also the queue size is zero right
because there is no message in the queue
which needs to be processed right so
this is where we are hitting this
condition and at this condition what we
want to do
is we want to attempt to delete these
instances because
q size is zero then the auto scaling
group this asg
asg
and my handwriting is really bad but
this auto scaling group right here it
should try to down scale the ec2's the
pool of ec2s it owns right this asg owns
it and therefore it tries to downscale
it downscaling i mean it tries to
destroy these instances which are
present but there is another thing which
we can do here is we can protect this
ec2 instance from being destroyed by
setting a deletion lock right so ec2
instances can
set a lock like this
where auto scaling group will not be
able to destroy it and when we will do
it just before the processing starts
right so this is the processing phase
this is the lock
and once the processing phase is over
then you just unlock the ec2 instance
right so the moment you the video is
processed and stunned then you unlock it
and asg sees that hey there are no queue
items i want to be you know downscale it
sees that the ec2 instance is unlocked
it destroys it and you get a scalable
architecture which upscales and
downscales depending on what is your
need at the time so this was a very high
level overview of the architecture and
how it works obviously this is more
complicated in the code and how you
place all the architecture bits and
bytes but this is fundamentally how and
what powers code them even today in
terms of video processing and
maybe a lot of other sites as well
because this is an approach which is
scalable if you want to make any changes
you just need to make some changes in
the ec2 scaling part and the best part
is this whole process is very very cheap
i'll just quickly give you an idea why
because you will see that right here
uploading to s3 has a cost of zero
dollars right because s3 has
ingress bandwidth as free that means if
you are uploading something to s3
uploading to aws cloud aws does not
charge you for that then sqs sure has
some fees but it's relatively lower
i mean it's not that much
right then let's see cloud watch alarm
also has some fees but it's again
relatively lower
these ec2 instances which you create
need not to be reserved instances right
these instances could be spot instances
so what a spot instance is spot instance
is additional compute capacity available
to aws which they will sell at a 50
to 80 lower price right so if you pay
for example i don't know like 10 cents
an hour for an ec2 instance you can very
well get it for like two cents or three
cents an hour right so that's possible
ec2 has the spot instance concept but
the only drawback for this is aws can
terminate this any time giving you a two
minute notice but for this task it does
not really matter let's say this easy to
get instance gets terminated then this
message this message which it took will
get restored in the queue right and
would be picked up by another ec2
instance later so that's completely fine
so you get a very low cost here of
processing on ec2 because you can have
big machines processing but at a very
relatively smaller cost then again
this machine when this downloads files
to ec2 from s3 that is also free because
this is running inside aws
infrastructure right so this part can be
made free if you have ec2 then basically
the infrastructure in a similar region
finally when you upload it from ec2 to
production s3
that is also free because like i said
it's the charge for uploading it to
basically s3 is zero and the only price
which you pay realistically which which
you should consider actually
is when people start hitting your video
right the data transfer cost because
this is where amazon makes real money
because their data charge is pretty high
but rest of the stuff is pretty good
right so yeah i mean this this model is
i think i ran some numbers and if you
consider for example amazon's media kit
which is a all in baked in solution for
this this is probably i don't exactly
remember what the number was but it was
close it was definitely above 10 times
even 20 times cheaper right so this
model when you deploy it yourself it's
20 times cheaper but again it increases
the difficulty of your architecture but
if you're like me
back in the days if you're simply free
and want to experiment with this this
would actually make a great great system
architecture project on your resume if
you would like to have a job like that
for example creating a full
infrastructure full architecture design
from scratch so i hope this video was
beneficial to you if it was make sure
you leave a like and subscribe to the
channel that is all for this one i'm
gonna see you in the next video really
soon
[Music]
you